هذا اخر تحذير وعلى الولايات
المتحدة ان تمنع طائراتها من
الاقتراب من الحدود الروسية.
هكذا قالت موسكو للامريكان ودول
الناتو ترد باعتراض طائرة روسية
فالى اين المفر. فهناك ازمة
دولية قد تشعل فتيل الحرب
العالمية بينما الدفاع الروسية
تعلن وصولها الى حالة الحرب.
ودول غربية تعلن استعدادها
للمجازفة بمواجهة الدب الروسي في
اوكرانيا وواشنطن تدرس ارسال اف
ستة عشر الى كييف. بل اقترب خطر
الحرب الكبرى. وبعد صفقة
الغواصات. الصين تجمع حلفائها
للرد على تحالف يوكوس ومنطقة
المحيطين هي الفيصل. فلمن ستكون
الغلبة؟ الاوروبيون يتوددون
للجزائر بالعروض السخية والعراق
لا انتهاك للسيادة بعد اليوم.
لغة الحرب. موسكو تحذر واشنطن.
هي ازمة غير مسبوقة وهي شرارة قد
تشعل حربا لا تنطفئ. واشنطن تتهم
وموسكو تنفي ودول غربية تستنكر.
والامم المتحدة تدعو للحوار
وتجنب العنف. نعم يا سادة. وبعد
ان سقطت المسيرة الامريكية
القيادة الامريكية في اوروبا
تقول ان طائرتين روس حلقتا امام
المسيرة الامريكية والقتا الوقود
عليها عدة مرات. ثم اصطدمت
احداهما بمروحة الطائرة بدون
طيار. ما دفع القوات الامريكية
الى اسقاط الطائرة ام كيونان في
المياه الدولية. يا لها من قصة
هوليودية. وكأن طائرتي روسيا
قامتا بالبسط على المسيرة ام
كيولاين. فسقطت في مياه البحر.
ايعقل هذا! سنة الجواب لكم. لكن
وبالعودة الى ازمة سقوط المسيرة
الامريكية ذات الاثنين وثلاثين
مليون دولار فيبدو انها لن تمر
مرور الكرام. فهذه هي المرة
الاولى التي تدخل فيها الطائرات
العسكرية الروسية والامريكية في
اتصال جسدي مباشر منذ ان شنت
روسيا حربها على اوكرانيا حيث
استنكرت الدول الغربية ذلك واصفة
تصرفات روسيا بان متهورة وغير
احترافية. ليبدأ الشد والجذب
فالجميع يبحث عن حطام الطائرة
ومهما كانت الاسباب فالسفن
الروسية اقرب بكثير من اي وسيلة
امريكية ستأتي للبحث عن الحطام.
ليعلنها البنتاجون الروس لم
ينتشل حطام الطائرة المسيرة. لكن
في الحقيقة فواشنطن تخشى حصول
روسيا على معلومات المسيرة
الامريكية صحيفة نيوز ويك. هنا
الخارجية الامريكية تظهر بعضا من
هدوئها. بالقول انها مسحت عن بعد
برامج حساسة بالمسيرة قبل سقوطها
لمنع روسيا من جمع معلومات سرية
وفق شبكة سي ان ان. اذا لماذا كل
تلك الجلبة من اجل انتشال
الحطام? يجيب المتحدث باسم
الخارجية الامريكية ان تقييمهم
لحادث المسيرة انه لن يكن مقصودا
وسببه عدم كفاءة الطيارين الروس.
لكن قبل ذلك كانت واشنطن قد
استدعت السفير الروسي لديها
لانطونوف لتسليمه مذكرة احتجاج
ويا له من استدعاء جلب الردود
القاسية على الامريكان. فبدأ
انطونوف قائلا ان بلاده لا تريد
مواجهة مع الولايات المتحدة لكنه
تساءل ماذا لو اقتربت طائرة
روسية من مضيفا ان موسكو اعلنت
منطقة التصادم بانها منطقة
عمليات عسكرية وحذرت من دخولها
وصلت الرسالة ليردف قائلا على
الولايات المتحدة ان تكف عن
الطيران بالقرب من الحدود
الروسية. ليتدخل الامين العام
للامم المتحدة انطونيو جوتيريش
بدعوته واشنطن وموسكو الى الحوار
وتجنب التصعيد. ليهرعرع وزير
دفاع الامريكي لويد اوستون
للاتصال بنظيره الروسي سيرجي
شويجو لمباحثة الحادثة وفق وزارة
الدفاع الروسية. وهنا نفض حلف
الناتو غباره للرد على سقوط
المسيرة الامريكية. حيث اعترضت
طائرتان عسكريتان احداهما
بريطانية والاخرى المانية مقاتلة
روسية بعد رصد دخولها المجال
الجوي لحلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو
بالقرب من استونيا بحسب سكاي
نيوز بانتظار الرد الروسي
كالعادة. اليكم المصدر. الخبر
العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل حيث
نقلت شبكة سي ان ان الاخبارية
الامريكية عن وزارة الدفاع
البريطانية قولها ان طائرات
بريطانية والمانية اعترضت
الثلاثاء طائرة روسية قرب المجال
الجوي الاستوني. مهلا مهلا مهلا.
الا يذكركم سقوط الطائرة
الامريكية باسقاط المنطاد الصيني
ان يشتم رائحة الانتقام الصيني
ولكن باياد روسية فالزمن قاض
عادل. يبدو ان موسكو تحضر لشيء
اخر ايضا هنا شركة روستيخا
الروسية تعلن ان انتاج الذخيرة
في روسيا وصل الى مستوى حالة
الحرب. بينما قال وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو ان كل الظروف
متوفرة لمضاعفة الانتاج وان
روسيا في استعداد كامل مواجهة.
ومن المعارك الثانوية الى
المعركة الحقيقية على الارض
الاوكرانية وبالتحديد مدينة
باخموت وهي عنوان المعركة
الحالية. وبعد ان كانت قوات كييف
على وشك الانسحاب من المدينة ها
هو الرئيس الاوكراني جولودي
ميرزلنسكي يقول ان اجتماعا
للقيادة العليا للجيش اتخذ قرارا
بمواصلة الحفاظ على مدينة باخموت
وحمايتها فهل حصل على وعود غربية
يا ترى بينما قالت الدفاع
الروسية ان قواتها تتقدم من
الجهة الشمالية الغربية للمدينة.
من جهتها قالت هيئة الاركان
الاوكرانية ان قواتها صدت تسعين
هجوما روسيا في مختلف الجبهات في
الساعات الماضية. ومن اوكرانيا
الى الجارة بولندا التي يبدو
انها ستكون التالية للدب الروسي.
حيث افاد المتحدث باسم الحكومة
البولاندية بان تمتلك قائمة
باسماء الدول التي ستمد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات تسعة وعشرين الا انها
لن تعلن عن اسمائها. مضيفا ان
بلاده مستعدة لامداد اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات في حال كانت ضمن
مجموعة من الدول وليس على
انفراد. لتنضم امريكا الى حفلة
الداعمين. حيث قال موقع بوليتكو
انه اطلع على رسالة من اعضاء في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي من الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي طالبوا
فيها وزير الدفاع لوفيد اوستن
بتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات
امريكية من طراز اف ستة عشر فهل
تجرؤ واشنطن على هذه الخطوة? ومن
الحروب النارية الى السياسة
الروسية. وبعد ان استقبل بوتين
رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد
هو الزعيم الروسي يتجه اليوم
ليصلح بين سوريا وتركيا وذلك بعد
ان اصلح بين ايران والسعودية
باشراف مباشر من الصين. وخلال
اللقاء في قصر الكرملين اكدت
التقارير ان بوتين يعمل على قمة
تجمع اردوجان بالاسد ليؤكد بشار
الاسد ان سوريا تقف مع روسيا ضد
النازية القديمة والجديدة. الصين
تستدعي الحلفاء وقت التراخي لم
يحن بعد. وها نحن ذا امام تجمع
التحالفات اقتربت من الاندلاع.
ليعلنها الامريكان اولا ان
المواجهة لن تكون ثنائية بين
بكين وواشنطن في منطقة المحيطين
الهادئ والهندي وانما متعددة
الاقطاب. وذلك هو الحال الذي
فرضته اتفاقية شراء استراليا
لغواصات هجومية تعمل بطاقة نووية
بموافقة امريكية وبريطانية. بكين
اصبحت امام قوة ثلاثية عالمية
مكونة من امريكا وبريطانيا
واستراليا في منطقة المحيطين
صفقة الغواصات هذه ستجبر الصين
على عدم الاقدام على غزو تايوان
او هكذا يعتقد الامريكيون. فهل
هو كذلك حقا ليأتي رد اصحاب
العيون الضيقة باعلان وزارة
الدفاع الصينية عن انطلاق
مناورات عسكرية الى جانب قوات
ايرانية وروسية في خليج عمان
الهندي تحت اسم حزام الامن
البحري الفان وثلاثة وعشرون.
وهنا تعمل ايران وروسيا والصين
على تعميق تحالفاتهم في مواجهة
الحلف الغربي لا سيما مع امريكا.
نعم يا اصدقاء التوتر يشتعل بين
امريكا وبريطانيا واستراليا من
جهة وروسيا والصين وايران من جهة
ثانية بعد اعلان صفقة الغواصات
النووية الاسترالية لتعلن بكين
ان طهران وموسكو هما حلفاؤها ضد
تحالف اوكوس. وان اردتم المزيد
فما اكثر الراغبين بالتحالف معنا
افهمتم? هكذا يقولها اصحاب
العيون الضيقة. الاحداث
والتطورات. مسؤول السياسة
الخارجية في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل يصل الى الجزائر
مؤكدا التعاون مع الجزائريين
لاسترداد اموالهم المهربة. فما
كل هذا التملق والتقرب نحو
الجزائر هؤلاء خلال كلمة القاها
في ملتقى السليماني. اكد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني انهم لن يقبلوا ابدا
بان يكون العراق منطلقا لهجمات
ضد دول الجوار ولا ساحة لتصفية
الحسابات. مشيرا الى انه يجب على
الجميع احترام سيادة بلاده. رئيس
هيئة الاركان الاسرائيلي. يجب
الاستعداد حدث على جبهات عدة
تشمل ايران. ازمة المسيرة
الامريكية تصاعد الادخنة في
الاجواء العالمية. وكما يقول
المصريون ما فيش دخان من غير نار
فهل تكون هذه الازمة هي النار
الحقيقية ام ان للامم المتحدة
رأيا